-Here's how this works.
We're gonna have a number
of mystery objects
brought out in front of us,
and our job is to guest
what each one is.
The catch is that we have to
figure it out by touch alone.
-Okay.
-Are you ready for this?
-I have one condition.
-Yes.
-No spiders.
-No, I can't guarantee
you anything.
No, I literally -- Last time,
they got me with them.
-I'll literally die.
-No, I know.
I can't even talk about it.
They did that to me last time.
-With spiders?
-Yes.
-Like, I'll -- I'll --
-I know, I'm freaking out.
I can't even talk to you now.
-No, no.
-I'm freaking out.
[ Laughter ]
Let's just go.
I'll go first.
I'll be the first one.
Let's get our first object.
-Okay, okay.
-Get this over with.
Oh, my gosh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm freaking out!
-Can I see what it is?
-Yes, you can see what it is.
-If this is crazy,
I'm gonna run.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Oh, my God.
Why are you acting --
You're acting like
it's not anything.
Is it something?
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Aah!
[ Laughter ]
Ew.
Ew!
It's, like, warm, it's slimy.
It's like something --
Ew!
It's, like, slime or something?
I don't like it at all.
Stop, stop, stop.
So gross.
What is it?
Dog food or something?
Ew! It's disgusting.
What is it?
-I hope mine --
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh, my gosh.
Mashed potatoes and gravy?
What did you think,
I was gonna put my hand
all the way into it?
Get this out of here.
Oh, my gosh.
[ Laughter ]
Ew! Gosh!
All right, you're up.
No -- Oh, thank you.
-All right.
-What's going on?
[ Laughter and applause ]
No one told me about
this part of the game.
What is happening?
[ Laughter ]
It's way too much.
-Here, here.
-I have a hand full of Purell.
Yeah, I mean this all --
Okay.
-Okay.
-But now --
Yeah, now, I'm totally wet.
[ Laughter ]
Here we go, all right.
You ready for this?
-Okay.
-Good luck.
Kim, good luck.
You have 30 seconds.
-Just tell me if it's an animal.
[ Laughter ]
Please.
♪♪
It's an animal.
-Stop, stop, stop.
-Okay.
-Don't look at anyone!
Don't! Stop it!
-Is it an animal?
-Stop it! Stop it!
Kim, stop!
-Wait. If it's an animal...
-Stop!
-Is it a spider?
Is it a spider?
-No!
-No? No.
-Aah!
-Silence.
I'm gonna do this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They're not scaring me.
Stop.
I don't feel anything.
Aah!
[ Laughter ]
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Is it scary?
-No!
-Okay.
Oh, my God.
It feels like a stuffed animal?
[ Laughter ]
Is it a real animal?
-No, we'll give it to you.
It is a stuffed squirrel.
-Oh.
[ Dinging ]
Aah!
-No, it's a fake --
-Where is that hand sanitizer?
-We would never --
[ Laughter ]
-That is --
-Where's the hand sanitizer?
Please.
♪♪
-That's a real squirrel,
by the way, people.
-That was not a real squirrel.
-Yeah, I guarantee it.
-We would never --
No, it's a doll.
Aaah!
-Taxidermy.
-Here we go.
All right.
How many more of these
do I have to do?
Two more of these?
Okay.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Okay, here we go.
Wah wah wah.
Come on, dude.
Man up!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
What are you talking about?
Don't even --
Stop it.
-I would die.
-Stop it, stop!
-Stop it. Seriously, guys,
don't freak out.
Guys, seriously,
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Oh, my gosh.
[ Laughing ]
[ Cheering ]
I'm not doing my next one.
♪♪
-Waaah!
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Whoo!
What was that?!
-If mine is like that,
I'm not doing that.
-Aaaaaaah!
Aaaaaah!
I hate it!
It was fuzzy!
It was -- what --
It was fuzzy.
And again, it was warm.
I don't like anything warm.
-Wait. Let me see something.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Aah.
Aaaaaah!
[ Buzzer ]
Oh, my God!
[ Audience shouting ]
-Aaaaaah! Aaah!
Oh, my God!
♪♪
-Oh, my God.
Oh, my God.
I can't believe
you touched that.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
Can we get the Purell?
-That's real.
[ Laughter ]
That is real.
-That was scary.
I'm so sorry, buddy.
Oh, my gosh.
That is real.
And, oh, my God, no.
All right, please.
-My -- The squirrel was real.
-No, it was not.
-Yeah, it was.
-Here we go.
All right, Kim, you're up.
-The squirrel was real.
You guys...
-Oh, gosh.
-If mine is like that,
I'm not doing it.
-No, I swear I would tell you.
-Okay, I'm looking at you.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Am I okay?
-It's not --
-Is it an animal?
An animal?
-No, it's totally different.
-But I, like, smell an animal.
-No, you don't!
No, no.
Well, yeah, maybe --
maybe you do.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering ]
-You got to go.
You got to go.
-Watch that hand.
Watch that hand.
Oh, my God.
Watch that hand!
-I'm okay?
Watch my fingernails?
-Watch your fingernails!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay, okay, okay.
Is it an animal?
Just tell me.
Okay, okay.
[Bleep]
It's cold.
Aah!
What is it?
What --
Can I look?
It's slimy.
-Aaaaah!
-Aah!
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
[ Sad trombone plays ]
-It was a frozen crab leg.
-I hate this game.
-I know, I hate this game, too.
Get this thing out of here.
-We hate this game.
Please.
All right.
It's almost done
-Another one?
-It's the last one.
This last one
is the final round.
For this one, we're both
gonna get the same item.
The first person
to guess it, wins.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Oh, my gosh.
Come on.
We have to do it.
-I hate this game.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You have to do it.
Come on.
♪♪
We have to do it.
-What?
-I don't know, I don't know,
I don't know.
All right, come on.
[ Laughter ]
-Is it an animal?
-No!
-Ready?
[ Both scream ]
Aah!
-[ Laughing ]
Come on, dude!
-Okay, we can do this.
Let's really focus.
Aah!
-Aah!
-The looks on their faces.
-Don't look at anybody!
Don't look at me!
♪♪
[ Both scream ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I felt hair.
-Something touched me!
Is there, like, a wig?
[ Buzzer ]
Is it like a wig?
-Hang on.
-Aah!
[ Laughter ]
-How do you get in there, dude?
Oh, my God.
-Yoga.
I used my pilates, used my core.
-Oh, my God.
-My thanks
to Kim Kardashian West!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Stick around!
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show,"
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪